welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Aquaman
in the lost kingdom the sequel to The
billion dooll 2018 Aquaman and now the
final film of the DC extended Universe
Aquaman and the last Kingdom came out
right in the middle of my paternity
leave and now that the film is on
digital and now that I know this movie
wasn't going to trigger parents of
newborns by following the black man to
death of a prince storyline exactly
woohoo I can now break down this movie
scene by scene like all the other DC EU
films to point out the Easter eggs
details you missed and where I think
Batman was going to be in this movie
before his scenes were removed and yes
as a father to a newborn I spent way too
much time looking into some details they
put in the First Act of this movie and I
have proof that Aquaman is a freak who
drinks mir's breast milk to stay jacked
and a guy who I guess likes stinky
stinky messes after some sub aquatic
opening Studio titles we open on a
stormy night as the vessel named the
Sawyer 2 is being attacked by Pirates
and aquaban Jason Mamoa Glides in on a
seahorse storm the first film also began
with Arthur Curry attacking Pirates
black mantis's crew stopping them from
attacking a Russian submarine this film
begins a similar way and I think there's
a reason for that but I do love how
storm the seahorse lets out this little
horse the character of storm first
appeared in Aquaman number 23 in 1965
he's known as acting as Aquaman's
personal Modo Transportation on the high
seas storm doesn't have a tremendously
huge history he just kind of appears
whenever Aquaman needs to get somewhere
but as Arthur shares his name with King
Arthur it's nice to see him as a kind of
Knight on Horseback Aquaman narrates his
own story here in this intro saying I
talk to fish that is what Ben Affleck
Batman mockingly says to him when they
first met in Justice League the Aquaman
I hear you can talk to fish but here
Aquaman is owning it this whole prologue
can be seen as Arthur using his own
action figure to present a version of
himself to his son it's kind of like in
Marvel Loki restaging the events of Thor
the Dark World as a play in the opening
M of Thor Ragnarok and so I think we can
look at this opening scene on the ster 2
as being told from an unreliable
narrator the music Born to Be Wild from
the band Stephen wolf plays and yes we
are hearing from a band named Stephen
wolf and Aquaman literally fought
steephen wolf in Justice League Born to
Be Wild was used in the 1969 motorcycle
film Easy Rider and at the end of the
prologue we do see Jason Mamoa doing
donuts on what appears to be his own
motorcycle accustomed 1956
Harley-Davidson panad but in some shots
it weirdly has a headlamp and others it
does not and the audience for this
unreliable narrator story is Arthur's
baby son Arthur Jr and thankfully this
movie does not commit infanticide as
many of us worried it would based off
the fact that Black Manta killed baby
Arthur in Adventures Comics number 452
in 1977 the death of a prince storyline
but that fear is totally channeled as a
plot Point here in this movie now Arthur
Jr pees on Arthur and then later Arthur
Dodges a pee but the baby and mirror I
guess use water bending abilities to
redirect the P at Arthur and I have to
say as a father to a newborn son myself
I found this P joke to be well somewhat
relatable at first but straight up weird
the second time it happens like when
Arthur makes a game out of it by dodging
it like all of you parents of sons out
there you know how it goes it happens
once maybe a few times and then quickly
you learn to cover it with a wet wipe or
a cloth and then you change your kid
from the side and you like turn him you
never go straight down the runway
uncovered every time and then laugh when
he pees on your floor I just kind of
interpret this as Arthur being a guy who
spends half his time in the ocean and
looks like he smells like Driftwood just
not caring if his home smells like this
but then again considering Jason Mamoa
in this movie wears the same Royal
Hawaiian Hotel bath robe that he wore in
an Earth Day Instagram post where he is
sleeping in a van in a parking lot and
is making a big sloppy mess he clearly
just walked on the set wearing whatever
he was wearing that day and I just can't
imagine this guy cares that much what
anything smells like now throughout this
opening sequence we see Amber herd roran
as Mera yeah she gives birth to Arthur
Jr via a water birth and I'm pretty sure
that newborn is partially CG or it's
like a Clos mouth prop with CG added
because take a look at that mouth that's
definitely a visual effect to make the
mouth stretch open like that after Amber
herd's high-profile legal disputes with
Johnny Depp there have been various
reports that her role in this film was
cut down during the re-shoot process
process her reduced role along with
things like William Devo vco being
killed off screen which is part of the
restructuring that may have led to this
film feeling pretty disjointed in July
2022 is actually reported that Ben
Affleck would appear as Batman in this
movie and The Hollywood Reporter claimed
that Michael Keaton filmed a scene for
this movie as his version of Bruce Wayne
to follow up his appearance in the flash
but this Michael Keaton scene was pretty
confusing to test audiences which is why
Ben Affleck reportedly joined these
re-shoot but then after various recuts
of this movie and various new rounds of
test screenings the final version of the
film excluded both Affleck and so you
may be asking where an Aquaman 2 would
Batman have fit in I think it is in this
opening montage and it explains a lot of
what I've been talking about like notice
we cut away from the Indian of the
Sawyer 2 with this guag of Mamoa kicking
a pirate and we match cut on him kicking
his father Thomas's chair that crew of
The Boat just cheers like a group of
kids and doesn't it kind of seem like
that's the kind of reception Arthur
would want from his son to cheer at his
heroics we never learned much about the
Sawyer 2's circumstances like how that
all got wrapped up how they got into it
the scene just seems weirdly cut short I
think Batman was going to appear in an
early in the movie Cameo on this boat
the way Wonder Woman cameos in the
opening sequence of the flash I think
Arthur was going to have a Batman action
figure in his story to his baby son and
the joke was that when we cut to this
fictitious story it was going to be
Michael Keaton Batman because that would
be the Batman from Arthur's childhood
imagination rather than the Batman from
The Real World and that would reveal
this whole Sawyer 2 incident to just be
his fantasy where he would be washing
away his guilt from the Messier Pirate
Rescue where black mantis's father got
killed but my theory is that when they
tried to put this in front of test
audiences they were like wait why is
Batman Michael Keaton I don't get it
like are you saying Michael Keaton is
the Batman of the DCU so then Warner's
like they don't get it and then they're
like okay fine we'll just re-shoot it so
that it'll be the normal DCU Ben affle
Batman but then audiences were like wait
we don't get that either so then the
Warner was just like screw it no Batman
for anyone honestly like that or some
version of that is what happened here
like I'm 72% certain and really what
fuels my theory is that Jason Mamoa
received a story by credit for this
movie that's pretty rare for a lead
actor in a superhero movie like Edward
Norton definitely got Story by for the
2008 Hulk film Paul Rudd got co-
screenplay credit for the 2015 Ant-Man
movie but that's just because he and
Adam McKay basically took over that
script when Anar Wright left the project
so what was Jason mima's contribution to
the story I think it was just because
the actor improvised a lot of this fight
with the action figures and it was going
to be this film's whole opening Arc to
have an Aquaman Batman fantasy team up
from his point of view thank you to help
for sponsoring this video A new year is
a great excuse for finally tackling the
stuff that you put off last year and if
one of the things you've been putting
off until 2024 is taking proper care of
your mental health better help can help
you get started and hey no judgment for
waiting starting therapy can be hard and
the right therapist for you might not be
in your area and some people struggle
with the face-to-face interaction of
therapy with better help you can have
your therapy sessions as a phone call as
a video chat or even via messaging if
you prefer that whatever is the most
comfortable version of therapy for you
just click the link in the description
and answer a few questions about what
you're looking for from therapy and what
your preferences are better help will
then match you with the therapist from
their Network that's right for you if
you don't really fit with that therapist
which is a common thing with therapy you
can easily switch to a therapist for no
additional cost without stressing about
insurance who is in your network or
anything like that if you think you
might benefit from therapy consider
better help click the link in the
description or visit betterhelp.com neww
rockstars clicking that link helps
support this Channel and also gets you
10% off your first month of better help
so you can connect with a therapist to
see if it helps you now in this man cave
at their home you can see a license
plate on the wall reading hunk 357 and
the Thomas is reading a blue book titled
my mystery ships if you look closely
this is actually a personal account from
a British rear Admiral Gordon Campbell
about his experience with German OTS
during World War I which I kind of see
as a setup for Black mantis crew comeran
Atlantean Tech and mystery submarines
and as we see the rest of Arthur's life
since the events of the first film
cheering at an illegal cage fight that
he breaks up and participates in he
actually a human deep sea diver I think
this is Peter Mortimer the scavenger an
Aquaman villain from the comics thanks
to Brandon barck and hter Navaro for
helping me find that one and of course
toor Mor returns as Thomas Curry and
it's just great to see the guy stardom
since the 2018 film increase as he's
returned to play Boba Fett in the Star
Wars series on Disney plus they share
some guinnesses just like they did in
the pub in the previous film Jason Mamoa
is a huge Drinker of Guinness and in
fact he credited drinking Guinness for
helping him achieve his enviable
physique for the scene where he swims
away from Bruce Wayne shirtless in
Justice League Mamoa even had his own
line of Guinness beer back in 2016
apparently his personal trainer has
structured his entire diet and his carb
intake around drinking a Guinness a day
but bear with me here inside this fridge
dangerously close to these guinnesses
are several bottles of mea's breast milk
I count 10 bottles and every single one
of them is full over 8 O each so in
total that is like 85 o which again
parents of newborns out there Jesus
Christ that is a lot to keep in the
fridge at any given time mirror would
have to be pumping Round the Clock or
just maybe expressing a lot per day and
I don't think Arthur Jr would be feeding
that much like at Peak when babies this
age are breastfeeding it's like like at
most like 24 o per day but notice the
more important detail is that none of
these bottles are labeled when you're on
like pumping rotation like that you
always label them to know when that milk
came out and when it's getting close to
expiring especially if you're just
refrigerating it as opposed to deep
freezing it so who knows when this milk
supply was pumped but I assume the fact
that none of them are labeled is that
they all came from just that day because
you only label things if you're doing it
over the course of multiple days so no
kid this size is taking in 80 ounces of
breast milk per day I don't care if he's
like 3/4 Atlantean the kid's stomach
could only be a certain size so why am I
ranting about this here's what I'm
getting at folks I believe Arthur Curry
is drinking Mira's breast milk that's
why he keeps it in his beer fridge he
doesn't care when it came out this guy's
just guzzling it down because there is a
weird trend of bodybuilders paying for
Black Market breast milk this is a thing
I guess some people do I believe that's
why mirror is off screen for most of
this movie our girls pumping so yeah
Warner you didn't think a daddy of a
newborn would be breaking down your
freaky little movie did you I'm on to
you okay so Thomas gives Arthur some
words of advice and Ma reap in the DC CE
Thomas Curry is Maui making Arthur of
Maui descent in the first film we
actually saw them do hungi which is a
traditional greeting in Maui culture
that's where two people touch their
noses and their foreheads together
Arthur also wears a jade around his neck
which is a greenstone Bound in New
Zealand that has long been used by Mai
people to make fishing hooks weapons and
jewelry and we learned that Arthur Jr
can also telepathically communicate with
sea creatures setting up his distress
Beacon to his father in the final act so
the title of Aquaman theas kingdom comes
out of a giant Glacier that cracks on
the other side of young Arthur's
aquarium to forhad how cordax this
movie's primary villain will appear in
the movie as he is thought out of ice
moving on to the Arctic base of the
mercenaries led by David Kane AKA Black
Manta with Yaya Abdul mantin the second
back reprise in his role from 2018
Aquaman he's again a major antagonist in
this movie the camera pans on his
damaged battle suit which David wore in
Sicily when he was defeated by Aquaman
in the first movie Randall Park returns
as Dr Steven Shin that was a scientist
whose rantings about the existence of
Atlantis had him dismissed as a crackpot
but in the post credit scene of the
first movie shin has rescued Black Manta
implying that the two have an alliance
in order to find Atlantis and that's
where we find them now when Dr Shin and
a fellow scientists fall into a deep
crevice they encounter an unseen
tentacle monster who drags one of them
away the creature is simply titled
tentacle based on the bfx artist
portfolio page on Art station they say
this was all probably solid ice until we
started heating the planet Aquaman and
the lost kingdom contains a not so
subtle commentary on climate change the
titular Lost Kingdom of the film is an
ancient evil frozen in ice that's slowly
being thought out due to worldwide
warming temperatures one of the real
concerns about climate change is the
thawing of ancient diseases and bacteria
which we as humans would be biologically
unprepared to De with just another thing
to keep you all up at night because if
I'm not sleeping neither are you and I
love the details that this place was
frozen rather quickly rather than
something that occurred over eons of
time but rather some kind of magic from
atlin because look at those birds they
were frozen mid-flight in the ice and a
quick reminder that the Seven Kingdoms
are Atlantis zebel that's the kingdom of
mea and her father nus the fisherman
that's the most technologically advanced
of the kingdoms these are the folks who
have fish tails instead of legs the
brine that's home to the crustation like
people and the undersea volcanoes the
trench that's home of the trench it's a
sightless nocturnal subspecies and
that's how you would get to the hidden
sea and dead King's Island from the
first film The deserters that's a
kingdom of ruins under the sah desert
and in this film The Lost Kingdom which
we will learn is necris where cordax
ruled David holds up the pieces of the
black Trident and we get a glimpse of
cordax which is kind of presented as a
horror demonic force cordax is later
explained to be the brother of King
atlin which makes him distantly related
to Aquaman in the comics necris was
actually ruled by a different character
a villain named meanwhile cordex
was also in the comics as an exiled
member of the atlantan royal family
Aquaman and last Kingdom kind of
combines multiple characters 5 months
later the TV broadcast is showing the
global broadcasting system or GBS
reporting on the spiking global
temperatures GBS has appeared in the DCU
before in titles such as Man of Steel
Shazam and the first Aquaman it's kind
of like the whih of the DCU the Council
of houses calls an emergency meeting due
to another plague outbreak this council
is led by Caron led by India Moore who
in the comics is an anthropomorphic
tiger shark but in this film is a human
looking woman Caron's tiger shark form
is is a foe to both Aquaman and Green
Lantern in the comics but here is just
kind of more of a political adversary
also playing one of the members of the
council is Natalia saffran who is a wife
of producer and co-ceo of DC Studios
Peter saffron she also played
Kaleidoscope in The Suicide Squad we
learned that volco Arthur's Mentor from
the first film played by William defo
was killed recently off screen during
one of these plagues which yeah it's
just CCO right according to director
James Juan this was a scheduling
conflict but still just kind of weird to
not have him here Black Manta Dr Shin
and the crew use an ancient atlantian
submarine to sneak into Atlantis we see
that Dr Shen has been finding these old
ships and retrofitting them with new
tech in the last 5 months just 5 months
but really what fuels it is oricalcum
orac calcum is a real world metal that
is recounted in the origin story of
Atlantis by Plato the word is Greek for
Mountain copper and it's considered to
have a traditional copper red color not
like the green it appears to have in
this movie although the copper does turn
green when corroded by saltwater that's
how verree is formed the color of
corrosion also hints at how toxic it is
and the DC Comics or Calcom also has the
ability to astr project and influence it
intelligent beings which explains how
cordax is able to possess black manood
and fill his mind with institutional and
ancient knowledge after he picked up the
Trident on the approach to atlantian
Vault toppo appears in the comics toppo
is a very intelligent octopus who
assists Aquaman who made his first
Comics appearance in Adventure Comics
229 in 1956 he's gone through several
reinterpretations in the comics over the
years appearing with a more
humanoid-like appearance in the post-
crisis DC and becoming more monstrous
like thulu in the new 52 era you may
remember toppo was actually that
drumming octopus in the first Aquaman
film during Arthur's battle with orm in
the arena Atlanta explains that toppo
here stands for tactical operations and
pursuit operative and she does reference
too's musical talents as we saw before
he also plays a variety of musical
instruments when the alarms are
triggered black mantis crew member
Stingray steers the ancient sub toward
the Atlantis entrance gate all hell
breaks loose in Atlantis we see
atlantis's markets and at the center of
the city is the giant statue of King
atlin I really do love the design of
everything in Atlantis the vessels
include animal inspired designs like
shark jet skis a giant sea turtle ship
there's Manta Ray inspired fighter ships
it all looks really vibrant and really
cool miror gets blasted by black manta's
energy beam while Arthur stops an out
ofc control train and I've ranted about
this before but like I don't understand
how the passengers of this thing would
be at risk when they are underwater like
couldn't they just swim out the windows
and then like slowly Glide to a stop on
their own like with the buoyancy forces
gravity isn't really the same underwater
so are they really going to be in that
much danger if they like Abandon Ship
King nus returns to this movie played by
Dolph lungren he explains black manta's
new weapons that use ultrasonic energy
to disrupt the nervous system to break
orm out of his prison in the deserter
Kingdom nus gives Arthur a special blue
stealth suit the blue suit first showed
up in the 1986 Aquaman miniseries
designed by Neil Posner as a part of the
series that had Aquaman and Mira in
Florida that allowed him to camouflage
in the water James Juan posted that he
and writer David Leslie Johnson were
inspired by the 80s blue suit and said
that it was atlantian Tech based on a
seop pod's camouflaging ability form is
guarded by Blood drinking deserters
deserters being an atlantian tribe who
in the comics were the last Kingdom to
be accepted into Atlantis by King atlan
during his Reign neris explains that the
deserters are vampiric who turned to
surviving on blood instead of water when
the Sahara went dry during the making of
the lost kingdom James Juan
intentionally wanted to pay homage to a
number of Ray Harry house and Sci-Fi
movies one of them the 1965 planet of
the vampires during the prison break
sequence Arthur references Cast Away
that's the Tom Hanks Robert zcas film
where Hanks ends up looking like Patrick
Wilson does here and speaking of Wilson
Tom Hanks be friends of volleyball named
Wilson in that movie later on Arthur
references as caban that's a prison from
the Harry Potter series also during
their bickering you may have noticed
that Arthur says and he beat or with
quote no prep time which is a common bit
when DC fans debate who Batman could
beat saying that with enough prep time
Batman could beat anyone which is true
he could now orms initially thin
appearance was likely the result of a
body double under that beard and that
wig because Wilson reportedly did 400lb
deadlifts to get in his jacked shape for
this role Joel Adrien is credited as
Wilson's body double but that guy looks
pretty ripped too so I don't think it's
him but but there is another stunt actor
named Felix leech who did stunts for
Aquaman 2 and he is an accomplished
dancer who's in very good shape better
shape than I'll ever be but he does have
a more slender build and I think he
might have played skinny more Arthur and
orm bicker on their way to the sunken
Citadel sunken Citadel made of sunken
ships from around the world orm
describes it as the one place in the
world where the scum of the land and sea
mangle yes certainly anage to Obi-Wan
Kenobi's Yelp review of the Mosely Cana
you will never find the more wretched
Hive of scum and villainy and we meet
Kingfish voiced by comedian Martin Short
kingfish in the sunken Citadel quite
obviously bring up comparisons to Jaa
The Hut who had his own den of Thieves
on Tatooine in his Palace there's a
roulette wheel with a bouncing Pearl in
a wheel of oysters Aquaman gets
information out of Kingfish by
suffocating him in the comics this is
actually how Aqua baby gets killed Black
Manta put him in a sphere which was
slowly filled with air something that
that child could not breathe but again
don't worry he doesn't die in this movie
we get to black man's Refinery which is
built on an island known as the devil's
deep Arthur taunts his brother over the
fact that he's never had burgers or
pizza or steak Arthur tricks or into
eating a cockroach which he calls the
shrimp of the land this comes up later
in the post credit scene when orm adds a
bug to his cheeseburger Arthur tells orm
look Loki I'm not asking for your advice
on this aha Loki whether an intentional
not to Marvel or just to Norse mythology
Arthur's name drop of Loki when talking
to orm does kind of remind us of the fra
relationship between Thor and his
adopted brother Loki in the MCU Arthur
and orm break into the base and take out
a bunch of henchmen before Dr Shin finds
them and surrenders Arthur wants to
knock him out and says he better start
talking or only you want Sasa so Sasa is
a Samoan word meaning to hit or strike
basically something you did not want to
hear your parents say and thanks to
Friend of the channel Tom Michaelson for
helping us out with the background on
that so Stingray and the crew fire up
the octobots they're not linked directly
to anything in the comics but director
James Juan wanted to create designs that
evoke the 60s era of DC Comics telling
Entertainment Weekly quote everything
about the lost kingdom came from my love
for the Silver age Aquaman comic book
which is the 1960s comic book so
everything about it has a very retro
feel black mantis shows up in a very
comic accurate new look complete with a
solid black muscle suit and chrome
Helmet or grabs the black Trident and
gets a good look at necris the lost
kingdom King nus shows up and destroys
the devil's deep as Black Manta and the
crew escape nus Atlanta Mera and the
returning Brian King voiced once again
by John ree Davies reunite with Arthur
and orm the Brian King hilariously
brings up the climactic battle in the
first Aquaman film where yes orb sliced
off the Brian King's right claw orm
details a war waged between the Brothers
King atlin and cordax the latter of whom
thirsted for the right to rule and used
the or calcum to seek it as well as
constructing the black Trident atlin won
the war and sealed cordax in the ice
wiping necris from the record of
Atlantis for Arthur however it's a
warning to not allow the Feud with a
brother to continue and to reconcile or
else the world could be destroyed
because atlan used blood magic to seal
cordax in his prison he needs ATL's
blood to escape which still exists in
the Royal DNA and they realize aquababy
is a new Target yikes but thank God the
kids just kidnapped manta's eyes glow
red in the dark like many descriptions
of the crypted known as The Moth Man
it's very very creepy I don't know how
anything that bulky could creep around a
house but still scary Arthur and the
Gang arried to find the lighthouse in
Ruins Junior's gone but Dr Shin sends a
secret signal to let Aquaman know where
they are heading so Arthur rides storm
into battle he calls upon the whales and
dolphins of the ocean to hit mantis's
ship with strong sonar to take out its
Cannon as they battle their way into
necris black mantis draws his blade
above the baby remember this is the same
knife he earlier told to Dr Shin I never
draw this blade unless it's going to
taste blood so Aquaman arrives and yells
get away from my son so there is an
improv game called give me back my son
where you scream Mel Gibson's line from
the movie Ransom get me back my and he
scream this in each other's faces trying
to make each other laugh Zack Woods
actually played this with Conan O'Brien
and Andy RoR on Conan give me back my
son give me back my son give me back my
son I bring this up because I feel like
Jason Mamoa is channeling this improv
exercise when he says get away from my
son because Jason Mamoa actually took
improv classes at UCB the same theater
where Zack Woods did improv as black
mana and Aquaman Clash Trident CX has
taken over you wear my brother's armor
and wield his Trident but you're only
half the man he was so cordax arm spills
Arthur's blood breaking the blood magic
and cordax awaken but orm hands Arthur
his Trident which Arthur throws
splintering cordax his Trident with his
own so necris begins to collapse and
Arthur tries to save David Kane but
black mantis says never and plunges into
the depths so in the aftermath the Brian
King we learn lost another claw they let
orm loose planning to tell everyone he
died in the battle in the final Montage
several news stations report on the
reveal of Atlantis to the world similar
to the ending of black panther when tala
revealed wakanda's true nature in front
of the UN they have this un and an
outdoor gathering with folding chairs at
Ellis Island I suppose it symbolize
Atlantic arriving to the shores of the
surface world as a kind of immigrant
group we see or trying to eat a
cheeseburger that is actually on the
Malibu Pier and yes we do see him in the
post credit see putting a bug on his
Burger the waitress who serves him is
actually ingred bisu the wife of
director James ju but don't go telling
that to everyone who hates James gun
because they believe that directors
putting their friends and loved ones in
movies is nepotistic and evil even
though this is something every director
from Christopher Nolan to Martin scor
sey they all do it in their movies folks
and yeah that includes your lord and
savior Zack SNY who put put Deborah
Snider and Batman v Superman so please
just shut up Arthur and his dad do a
traditional Mai Haka in the yard of the
lighthouse Arthur ends his speech in
front of the UN with this line direct to
camera I am
[Applause]
Aquaman oo okay Justice B MCU began with
Robert Johnny Jr declaring I am Iron Man
the DCU ends with this I honestly can't
believe the DCU signs off this way like
I know James Juan probably didn't intend
this but you know yikes I know marvel
Studio is struggling with quality
control currently but I cannot think of
a more striking contrast between a
superhero Cinematic Universe that
changed Hollywood Forever by doing most
of the things right and then this other
universe that did a lot of stuff wrong
in a video coming soon I'm going to do a
full autopsy of the DCU because I think
there are a few specific reasons why the
DCU had as much trouble as it did but
also some really shining wonderful
moments that I don't want our industry
to just like forget about and in this
video I'm going to reveal my final
official ranking of all DCU movies can't
wait for the comments on that one hey if
you like this video please give us a
like And subscribe to new rock stars I'm
Eric Boss thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
bye